I say this every time and never change
it that is not my body they used a
different body I don't know why they
probably shot that five feet from my
office they could have called me but
instead they got a very sickly in turned
[Laughter]
rickets disease you don't hear about
much in it you sure don't but I still
love it they still love rickets how to
control tonight this is called being
jet-lagged and I brought a lot of
Guinness with me all right
goodness good stuff check it out okay
anyway the premise is you push buttons
and a button it tells you what the show
is yeah you go for example I was
watching the NBA Finals I was enjoying
him having a good time watch the NBA
Finals and then I hit the info button
here's what it said it said two teams
vie to be the one to publicly reject an
invitation to the Trump White House
I was watching I was watching The
Bachelor I love that show can't get
enough of The Bachelor I was watching
The Bachelor yeah check on that show out
and then I hit the button and it said a
diverse selection of ambitious chlamydia
viruses live in and out of hot tubs then
I was watching I turned the TV and I saw
Antiques Roadshow and I was curious how
do they describe Antiques Roadshow so I
hit the button and it said elderly
burglars pawn there yeah people love
this next show I was watching Dancing
with the Stars yeah I was watching
Dancing with the Stars and then I hit
the info button and it said just three
more years till Kevin Spacey you know
it's true
maybe two maybe two yeah yeah little
women I was watching a little women
classic and then I hit the button and it
said you've watched the parody on
pornhub
now watch the non four-way incest
version well the audience just voted and
we went too far
[Laughter]
just so you know the camera wasn't on me
I read that joke wearing a gray sheet I
[Laughter]
was watching PBS that's right I like PBS
who doesn't yeah
watching PBS and then I hit the button
and it said your tax dollars allow
ballet and opera to live on well past
their natural death hey I was watching
the prices right yeah people love the
prices right then I hit the button said
if the contestants had to run up the
stairs and set it down
there'd be no survivor watching top gear
watching the show top gear
yeah I hit the button it said this is
Top Gear the car show not Top Gear the
gay bondage store near the airport which
is also worth a visit yeah yeah so I
flip from there I flip from there at a
Top Chef and I'm watching Top Chef and I
hit the button and it says this is Top
Chef the cooking show not Top Chef the
guy who hangs out at the gay bondage
store near the airport
and finally shark tank
I was watching shark tank yeah and then
I hit the button and it said wonder why
the hosts are always seated it's because
they're taking a dump on your dream
you
you